I imagine that they're just in turtlenecks.
No. You're thinking of the priest collar.
-Yeah but, like Irish people
they're always wearing turtlenecks.
I know. This font choice...
I'm cringing a little bit right now.
-Uh oh. -They just pushed the person in the wheelchair down!
You were right. Sweaters.
-They're all in sweaters.
[Man on TV] "How's the son?"
Man, they really laughed at that.
Are we supposed to laugh at that?
I like that blanket. That's really cute.
-The Jesus blanket. -Yeah.
I want that for my house.
[Man on TV] "Brandy! Brandy!"
I scream like that for Brandy too.
I don't think it's funny at all so far.
Am I going to offend a lot of people by saying that?
(Laughter)
I like her! -
She does not take "no" for an answer.
Do priests have bosses?
God.
Man, I 'm really liking Father Jack.
-I like Dougal.
I like his spacey-ness.
[Man on TV] I just want to get this Filum business over and done with.
--Filum? What Filum?
What's 'Filum'?
I know...I don't... (Laughter)
What's "Filum"?
[Man on TV] This is very serious.
Don't make a balls of it.
-Balls? -"Don't make a balls of it?"
[Woman on TV] Don't talk to me like that you big pile of (bleep).
-"Move, you big pile of shite."
What did he say to her?
-Oh my God.
-This just got real.
[Woman on TV] "I'll stick this up your ass!"
Those Irish have a dry sense of humor.
I'm definitely attracted to him.
-I'm attracted to him too.
(Laughter)
I mean there's not many options in this show.
There aren't very many options.
This couple's great.
She's really sassy.
She's just about to shank this guy.
[Man on TV] Down with this sort of thing!"
-"Down with this sort of thing!"
(Laughter)
-Maybe we should just introduce this into American culture. Carefully.
-Yeah!
-Father Ted careful now!
-Go on you old perv!
You old perv!
I'm gonna startaying "Feck."
- Me too. I like it.
-Feck you! You wanna Feck?
You feckin' eejit.
Is that? Am I doing it right?
I feel like this is ahead if its time for comedy.
-It's a little dated for me.
I want to give another episode a shot and see what it's all about.
-I'm hooked. I'm in. I want to know what happens.
-Me too.
I feel it would be in a lot of rap songs.
Like: "Feck."
"You are Deck."
(Laughter)
That is great right there.
You got that recorded right? That's going platinum.